el presidente italiano Sergio matarela
ha convocado a la líder del partido
hermanos de Italia Georgia meloni en la
tarde de este viernes al palacio
presidencial se espera que el jefe del
Estado italiano otorgue a meloni el
mandato para formar un nuevo gobierno
meloni debería posteriormente regresar
al palacio presidencial a presentar su
lista de ministros que debe ser aprobada
por el presidente Sergio matarella antes
de proceder con la ceremonia de
juramento del nuevo gobierno una
ceremonia que podría llevarse a cabo ya
desde este fin de semana Georgia melón y
se convertiría entonces en la primera
mujer en gobernar Italia desde el
nacimiento de la República italiana su
primer desafío será claramente el de
mantener viva la coalición con sus
socios Silvio berlusconi y líder de
fuerza Italia y Mateo salvini del
partido de ultraderecha en la liga una
co marcada por divisiones y
enfrentamientos internos como se ha
podido ver en estas últimas semanas
Cuando el partido de Silvio berlusconi
rehusó votar Hace unos días por el
candidato a presidente del senado
italiano presentado por Georgia meloni o
con las recientes declaraciones de
Silvio berlusconi en audios que
filtraron en la prensa italiana se oye a
verlusconi que elogia al presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin y pone en tela de juicio
la estrategia de la otan en Ucrania
audios que desataron la ira de Georgia
melón y que se disoció de estas
declaraciones un evento que pone de
relieve la fragilidad de esta coalición
que se prepara a gobernar Italia